the biden campaign has yet to respond
this morning to the president's positive
test
the former vice president who is older
than mr trump
did maintain social distancing during
tuesday's debate
biden has also stayed out of public view
for much of the past six months
campaigning virtually and avoiding any
large gatherings of supporters
our ed o'keefe is covering campaign 2020
for us ed good morning to you
have we heard anything at all yet from
the biden camp
as you just said tony not yet we are
awaiting a response from them but
remember over the course of this
campaign
well certainly over the course of the
pandemic the former vice president has
made the argument
that the president has failed to address
the coronavirus
and and that he would do better remember
also he has said that he and his running
mate kamala harris
are being tested regularly for covet 19
and that they would announce that they
ever test positive
a recent cbs news battleground tracker
poll of registered voters nationwide
found 50 percent
believe biden would do a better job of
handling the pandemic to the president's
38
percent today biden is scheduled to fly
to grand rapids michigan for an event
but again we've yet to hear whether he
still plans to keep that schedule today
he's
supposed to talk about the economy in a
state that he's hoping to win back for
democrats as a precaution overnight
however
his campaign did ask a reporter who was
with the president
during his trip to minnesota on
wednesday not to serve
in what's called the press pool today or
the group of reporters that travel with
him
as he flies across the country remember
the biden campaign has been incredibly
vigilant about the pandemic
over the course of the last several
months rarely holds events
they're very small everyone who goes
into them has their temperature
taken we get asked whether we have any
symptoms or have been in contact with
people
it's limited his exposure across the
country some
say that's a smart thing others say he's
potentially putting
his ability to win the race at risk but
i think today
you know we will see whether they keep
to that vigilance and decide to hold off
or whether he proceeds with his plans
remember 32 days to go in this election
and many americans are already voting
all of these overnight developments
put everything in flux anthony ed
o'keefe thank you ed